all right
what up peeps it's december 17th
2020. i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report
direct message we're going to be doing
four stories for you
but before i do anything today i got a
bit of good news this morning
i'm in a good mood and i want to share a
little something with you
before we show you the pictures for
those of you that read my book and
uh have been watching this show for for
quite some time i've mentioned this a
few times on the show before but
just a handful of times maybe three or
four times that's it
although i do write about it pretty
extensively and don't burn this book
when i
sort of came out politically which was
starting about five years ago right now
it was
about the winter of 2015 uh when i
started talking about like sort of how
crazy the left was going and that they
were no longer adhering to liberal
principles and what was happening on
college campuses and why are we
you know me at the time why are we the
leftists the ones that are canceling
everybody and calling everyone bigots
and racists and why aren't we
arguing and using logic and reason and
all of that stuff
two things happened at the same time on
one hand i started getting
all these new fans and i felt like i was
saying something important and relevant
it was something that
sort of everyone's talking about now but
i happen to be one of the first guys
talking about and i was getting all this
love and that was great and
our views were going up and all good
stuff there but the counter to that
and which in many ways was worse than
than the good stuff
which you know sort of almost like ate
the good stuff
was that i was getting an incredible
amount of hate so suddenly like the
unending twitter mobs
and you know former friends and former
colleagues of mine telling me that i was
a racist and a bigot and a nazi and all
of this stuff
and i never expected that like i just
thought oh i'm just saying what i kind
of think is wrong with the left and guys
let's be liberal let's talk about it
i'll invite you all on my shows like
let's work it out
but then i got this just unending
torrent
of hatred and people saying horrible
things about me and hit piece after hit
piece being written
and i'm all right and i'm racist and all
of that stuff
well then right about now about five
years ago i was getting my hair cut
and the girl who cuts my hair jazz is a
good friend of mine and i was getting my
hair cut
and she called david over and she said
you know you better look at this and she
busted out the mirror
so i could see the back of my head and i
was missing sort of huge chunks of hair
all over the place and we'll show you
the picture in just a sec
basically i developed a condition called
alopecia areata
which is where your white blood cells
start attacking your hair follicles and
they don't know exactly why this happens
i went for blood tests
checked i didn't have any infectious
disease or anything like that but in
essence that all they can chalk it up to
is stress
and what i didn't realize was i was
dealing with
you know a ton of stress by getting all
of this hate and i guess
and i've learned this since that i kind
of internalize my stress
uh i don't do it as much now as i used
to but i was internalizing all the
stress
long story short um i lost ultimately
about 40 percent of my hair i
ended up doing all sorts of um
experimental medications
let's show the first picture so this is
me this is about five years ago right
now
and it got significantly worse than that
and i'm not showing you this picture for
any sympathy
i i don't want any virtue signal points
or any of that stuff i'm just trying to
be real with you right now about
something
that i went through so uh it did get
significantly worse than that and you
can see it it's
pretty brutal and just huge chunks of
hair falling out shower it was all over
the
sink and all that well the reason i'm
mentioning this today
is that my my same girl jess who is a
good friend of mine
uh who now gives me illegal haircuts
here in los angeles she's
she's here right now in my house she
just gave me a haircut this morning and
let's put up the picture from this
morning
as of this morning i have all of my
hair back that is all my hair uh i don't
know why
my hair looks much browner there and
blacker in the other one if you want to
throw back to the other one i have never
colored my hair
in any way i give you my word so i don't
know what's going on there
but that's not the point the point is
that as of this morning after five years
of dealing with this and i write about
it pretty extensively in the book i went
under some
pretty experimental medication that
caused my body basically to break out in
hives all the time and i was hot all the
time and sweaty and itchy and gross and
miraculously
uh it affected basically every part of
my body except my face although i looked
exhausted all the time and i had huge
bags under my eyes because i couldn't
really sleep
i mean i dealt with this basically for
years it's the last couple years that it
did get better
and uh and i started changing my diet a
little bit doing more paleo stuff
and uh you know trying to eat foods that
are more anti-inflammatory
and a whole bunch of other stuff and
anyway as i've talked about it a little
bit publicly a lot of you guys have
reached out to me
about it and uh it sucks but but you
will get through it and by the way i'll
just say one other thing on this
um which is that you know i've heard
from a lot of
other people who are now public people
that when they started sort of talking
about generally what was going on with
the left or when they've come out
politically in any way or said that they
were trump supporters or whatever
when they get that that sort of just
massive
crazy amount of hate that you don't
expect and family members are turning on
you and friends are turning on you
and everything else i know for a fact
i'm not the only one that has had
a weird autoimmune thing happen i've
actually heard of a couple other people
that have had some version of alopecia
or people that have broken out and
things like like your body
is talking to you your body's talking to
you all the time and that that's what i
learned about this and i i changed some
habits
eating habits and exercise habits and
the rest of it and i'm just truly like
um
like i can barely come up with the words
for it like i'm just actually thrilled
when i saw those side by sides and
we have some pictures when it was worse
but i can't even show them because
because it's actually gross
so anyway so i'm just in a great mood
today we got four stories for you uh
before we get to any of that though
guys i want to talk about the glint pay
card you know what i'm talking about
over here it is a great way to get
involved in the gold game using your
glint pay card you can make purchases we
do have the holiday season even though
they've got us under a lockdown it is
the holiday season and i hope you're
going to be buying
hanukkah gifts and christmas gifts and
all that good stuff for your friends and
family
and using the glint pay card you can
either use gold or you can use
us dollars as a regular mastercard you
can just decide within the app what you
want to pay for so you can actually buy
coffee and gifts and sneakers and
sweatshirts and everything else
with gold it's a pretty great way to get
into the gold game buy and sell and
trade and all that good stuff
the glint card is issued by sutton bank
member fdic pursuant to license from
mastercard international
it's free to sign up so go to
glintpay.com reuben for more info and to
start purchasing gold today
that's glimpay.com reuben to get your
gold today
and now back to me and by the way you
know another thing that you can buy with
your glint
pay card is great hairspray people
always ask me
what's the deal and oribe i use oribe
hairspray there you go the fine
i think it's called the fine texturizing
spray or dry texturizing spray or
superfine something or other anywho okay
uh
let's talk about the democrats they're
they're mostly insane but
to varying degrees right so you're going
to get your really insane people
and you're slightly less insane people
i'm trying to find a not insane democrat
and i can only think of one her name's
tulsi gabbard
i've had her on the show we've become
friendly she just in the last couple
days has tried to
stop um men who transition into women
from being involved in women's sports so
they can't beat the crap
out of women she's being called a
transphobe for that she's also trying to
get something passed in her last days as
congress
saying that you can't have abortions
when the fetus can feel pain she's being
told she hates women for that
so she's basically on the way out she's
not running for congress and she'll be
done at the end of the year
uh which leaves us with not much in the
sanity department
for democrats these days and aoc is
already
saying that it's time for nancy pelosi
and chuck schumer to go
and she's basically saying that the
biden appointees
from the obama error era are are
horrible that's her word so there's a
quote from the intercept
she was asked about president-elect joe
biden bringing in hawkish members of the
obama administration
as well as officials from companies like
goldman sachs
mckinsey goldman sachs and mckenzie and
ocasio-cortez said it's horrible so
we've got some
some video it's actually some audio that
we're going to show
of her in just a second but what's
interesting here is that she's now
framing the obama people as hawkish now
yes obama did
all sorts of bombing in syria and he
arrested
journalists and did all kinds of stuff
but i thought he was supposed to be a
progressive hero and it's just so
fascinating
watching this snake now eat its tail
but let's listen in to miss
ocasio-cortez herself
are you ready to say pelosi and schumer
need to go
i mean i i i think so i mean and the
question is like this year for example
the hesitancy that i have
is that i i want to make sure that if
we're pointing people in a direction
that we have a plan
and my concern and this i
acknowledge as a failing as something
that we need to
sort out is that there isn't a plan how
do we fill that vacuum
because if you create that vacuum
there are so many nefarious forces
at play to fill that vacuum with
something
even worse and so
the actual sad state of affairs
is that there are folks
more conservative than even they are
willing to to kind of fill that void and
so
what i'm looking at right now is what
steps do we take
both in structural changes because a lot
of this is not just about
these two personalities but they are
also about the structural shifts that
these two personalities have led
in their time in leadership the
structural shifts of power in the house
both in process and rule to concentrate
power in party leadership for
of both parties frankly but in
democratic party leadership
to such a degree that an individual
member
has far less power than they did
30 40 50 years ago and so you know the
answer is yes the answer is
we we need to to shift power we need to
make sure that we
have a transition of power in the
leadership of the democratic party
man there's a chick who loves power no
note how many times she said
power she really really loves power
she's telling you that
she wants more power and i don't know
exactly what she's talking about about
structural stuff it's one thing to say
that these
these people she doesn't like some of
the policies that these people have but
when they talk about structural changes
it's like are you trying
to change the constitution you know you
might have to do amendments and that
takes a lot of votes i know they don't
like the constitution and they don't
like
doing things properly right going
through the proper channels to make
things happen
but what's fascinating about this and i
mean i hate to say it guys i've been
warning about this for a long time
the the split in the democratic party
has been so freaking obvious and if you
thought that the biden pelosi
schumer the old guard was going to have
enough
to stop the new crazies the squad and
the socialists and the marxists if you
thought that somehow
biden was going to stop it was and
schumer and pelosi were going to stop it
well you got another thing coming and oc
is
aoc aoc is putting them on
alert she's saying we're coming for you
guys either behave the way you want
or we'll get you and it's so funny
because she's basically describing them
as conservatives because what
progressives do is find
enemies everywhere if you're not as
progressive as me
you are now the enemy and she okay we
got to get rid of you guys it doesn't
matter nancy
sure you're you're a rep in san
francisco the most ridiculously
progressive place
on planet earth but that's not even
progressive enough
for us you're old and you don't behave
the way i want you to and that's why
i've got to destroy you
and chuck schumer of course uh gotta
take you out
too so what's interesting about this is
that
what silly little aoc doesn't understand
is that the progressives of tomorrow
will destroy her too right the
progressives of 2040 as i always talk
about with obama
the progressives of 2040 are going to
say aoc you weren't progressive enough
for us because you
ate meat or whatever whatever their
nonsensical thing of the day is
so they'll take her out too so there is
a silver lining to all of this
but what i think is really interesting
there is is also how she's sort of
framing the obama administration
as not progressive enough even though it
was the most progressive
uh administration we've ever had in the
united states so i've got another quote
from aoc that i think is really
interesting she says the
biden administration is bringing back a
lot of
obama appointees which depending on
where you are in the party may
sound nice i guess she said but i think
what a lot of people fail to remember
is that we now have a biden
administration that's bringing back a
lot of
obama appointees but when obama was
making
appointments he was bringing a lot of
clinton appointees
boy you know she sort of sounds like
donald trump there because you know what
she's talking about
she's talking about the swamp that these
administrations just bring in the same
failed people time and time again so aoc
i'm going to kind of give you a little
credit there you almost sort of get it
you almost sort of get it that people
who fail stay
in state government positions and they
move from administration to
administration making more bad decisions
all the time
but what's interesting about this is
obama is going to have to lay down the
law at some point if this party
is the obama party now if the clinton
machine is pretty much
destroyed and now it's the obama machine
that's behind the biden thing because as
we've been talking about it's obviously
not
78 year old dementia biden's
machine right if it's the obama thing he
better watch out
because what in essence aoc is we're
coming for you too
and they will come for everybody and
eventually she will come for herself
so anyway i wanted to just throw this
story out there because i think you
don't have to get lost in the like the
political minutia
of all the cabinet picks and who said
what about who but the general trend
of that the destructive force that is
progressive politics
i think it's just something to just sort
of know about in the back of your head
that they're here to destroy everything
and it's not just
here to destroy the scary conservatives
and right wingers those
people that believe in the constitution
and limited government it's that they're
here to destroy their own people they're
here to burn down
their own house and you know it seems to
me that we should pay a little bit of
attention
to that before we get to the second
story though i want to talk to you about
bowling branch guys what are millions of
americans and
three former u.s presidents have in
common
they all agree that bowling branch
sheets are the softest and most
comfortable
pure organic cotton sheets on earth
bowling branch cotton is rain
fed pesticide free and carries the
highest organic certification
which is why it's so soft because they
work with family owned mills from all
over the world to expertly weave
every set of bowl and branch sheets with
the highest level of craftsmanship
it's quality you can feel the moment you
open up the box i have bowling branch
sheets guys
they are ridiculously soft and
comfortable you have my word
and since they sell directly to you
bowling branch sheets start
at just 160 bucks their thousand dollar
quality for a fraction of the price plus
you can sleep on them for a month
absolutely risk-free
and right now you'll get 50 bucks off
any sheet set at bowlingbranch.com with
promo code ruben
that's b-o-l-l and branch dot com
promo code ruben for fifty dollars off
bowlingbranch.com promo code ruben
restrictions may apply
see bowlingbranch.com for details and
now back to me
all right segment two let's talk about
andrew cuomo
andrew cuomo in segment two i would say
i put this at segment two because he's
the second worst governor
in the united states we of course have
reserved that first spot for my governor
here
gavin newsom and let's not forget
hashtag recall
gavin 2020. let's get rid of that guy we
need 310 000 signatures and then we can
get rid of that absolute abject buffoon
but number two
in the worst uh governor the worst
gubernatorial guy we've got is andrew
cuomo and
uh we're not even gonna talk about his
ridiculous coveted regulations and what
he's doing to businesses and telling
people
that chicken wings don't count as a meal
which he literally did so he could close
bars
he actually now is banning the sales of
confederate
flags now i'm not here to defend the
confederate flag but let's get to the
quote
from governor cuomo and then we'll talk
about it this is from the new york post
governor andrew cuomo
signed a bill into law aimed at banning
the sale of
hate symbols such as the confederate
flag or the swastika
on state property even while admitting
the new edict might clash
with the first amendment and be struck
down as unconstitutional
the new law effective immediately
prohibits the sale of hate symbols on
public grounds including
state and local fares and also severely
limits their display and let's get a
quote from andrew himself
this country faces a pervasive growing
attitude of intolerance and hate
which i have referred to in the body
politic
as an american cancer okay so let's just
be clear about this
first off i'm fairly certain this is
unconstitutional he's even admitting it
already right
uh it's also a little you know he's he's
playing with language a little bit there
because what are you saying on
state grounds so that's as they said
they said that that's like state fairs
that are on public rounds or something
like that
but i am fairly certain that whether
something's on state
grounds or not uh that the government
can't come in
and tell you that you can't sell
something because they don't like it i
mean and if we're banning hate symbols
are you gonna
ban the uh the icon are you gonna ban
the donkey of the
democratic party because there's an
awful lot of hate there right um
and who's gonna decide what we can ban
and when we can ban it
and the rest of this so this type of
thing i don't even need to talk about
the confederate flag specifically here
because this obviously isn't about the
confederate flag and also what does he
really think he's accomplishing okay
we're going to ban the sale of the
confederate flag we're going to ban the
sale of swastikas
do you think that is going to ban the
ideas of racism
do you think that that's what it's going
to do or perhaps
work with me here do you think that that
actually might push those ideas more
underground and then have them fester
even more
right uh i think that that possibly
is what you would do so this is
unconstitutional
it's nonsensical and by the way he will
only label things
as hateful if they're the things that he
doesn't like
right is he going to ban the black lives
matter
logo i mean there's an awful lot of hate
there is he going to ban the antifa logo
they're basically a domestic terrorist
organization that's
that's rampaging through new york city
that's a city
in his state in new york they've
basically destroyed new york city my
family has fled new york city
a lot of other people have fled new york
city you're going to ban the antifa
symbol the sales of antifa stuff i
somehow doubt that andrew cuomo
and andrew cuomo i don't like you very
much
all right before we move on to segment
number three i want to talk to you guys
about
axon the world in 2020 can feel like an
unstable and dangerous place but we
can't live in fear i mean i tell you
guys that all the time
taser is giving people the confidence to
protect themselves by creating
life-saving defense
technology the people at taser believe
that a safer
self-defense is better self-defense
tasers lines of non-lethal
self-protection devices are small and
lightweight enough to carry with you
or in your glove compartment or in your
purse yet they're powerful enough to
incapacitate an attacker
they use an electrical charge to
immobilize attackers for up to 30
seconds
allowing you time to escape taser
devices come loaded with features like
laser assisted targeting and emergency
emergency dispatch
which will send response teams to your
gps location upon firing
more than 237 000 lives have been saved
with the taser network
of devices apps and personnel
protect yourself and your family with
tasers lines of smart defense
products call oh sorry taser is
available without a permit in most u.s
states
get the taser pulse plus or taser strike
light at taser.com
with promo code ruben you can save 15
off now at taser.com promo code reuben
that's t-a-s-e-r dot-com promo code
ruben restriction supply see cite for
details
and now back to me all right let's talk
a little bit about the
election because it is still a bit up in
the air yes joe biden has something
called the office of the president-elect
it's not a real office but he does have
that and
according to the electoral college at
the moment joe biden will be sworn in on
the 20th
we shall see i'll keep talking about
what's going on in the meantime
and the lawsuits and everything else and
there does still seem to be some weird
stuff going on with that dominion
software but maybe we'll all
add up to nothing my my feeling as i've
been telling you guys is something weird
is still there it seems very strange to
me that
joe biden who had virtually no support
and didn't campaign got 16
million more votes than the last time
barack obama ran for president but
putting that aside we'll talk about
obama from back in 2008 because you're
not going to believe this guys
back in 2008 barack obama
was uh worried about election fraud
this is video from msnbc
word from florida that they intend to
put out a mailing sort of a
of a campaign i mean an election process
whereby they make up for the uh
for the primary they had before which
was ruled out of order by the
democratic national committee and you
did not campaign and they're talking
about mailing it
people mailing in their ballots do you
trust the security the honesty of such
an election process
well i think we'd have to figure out uh
whether this was fraud proof i mean
oregon for example has a terrific
mail-in system
but they've already scanned everybody's
signatures who's registered to vote
so that they can check to make sure that
in fact the right people are voting
wow so back in 2008 that's
candidate not yet president barack obama
talking about we'd need to verify
signatures uh we'd have to make sure
that there's no fraud mail-in ballots
might have some issues he's talk he
goes on to talk about how the states
have different
different levels of protection and the
rest of it
so it's interesting that back then we
were allowed to talk about these things
but right now
in the midst of all of the weirdness
that's going on with the election
why is it that today on cnn you're not
going to hear any election officials
talk about these things that
maybe there were some problems with male
imbalance that maybe
having signature authentication would be
a good thing
and the litany of other issues that you
see little videos about on twitter and
you see some actual journalists they're
not mainstream journalists because you
can't be a real journalist if you're a
mainstream journalist
we see these people talking about these
things but why aren't we talking about
these things anymore
isn't that isn't that odd that seems odd
to me
by the way it's not just barack obama
because in 2008 when joe biden who
ultimately went on to become
uh barack obama's vice president when he
was running in 2008 a lot of people
forget he actually ran against obama for
the nomination in the first place
he also was talking about voter fraud we
played that video yesterday
so it's very interesting democrats
really used to talk about it and now
they don't and by the way let me just
get ahead on this one
if the situation was reversed
republicans would be doing the exact
same thing
absolutely hypocrisy knows no bounds and
has no party there's just no doubt about
that
but the point is that something
kinda ain't right and the media only
lets us talk about it from one way
and that is a bit of a problem someone
else also pointed out to me that there
was a documentary on hbo
earlier this year i haven't seen it so
i'm just going off what i heard
and you should check it out for yourself
if you think this is interesting but
that
hbo did a documentary that they put out
in february or march of 2020
where they were warning everybody about
fraud but it was sort of framed around
oh
donald trump might be the one to benefit
from the fraud but now that it seems
like the fraud might have benefited
somebody else
no no i doubt hbo is going to be pushing
that thing anymore so it's very weird
all right let's end on a positive note
though despite election fraud
and the rest of it great news out of san
diego people just three hours south of
me here
in los angeles a san diego judge has
ruled in favor of strip clubs
remaining open the county will stop
enforcing restaurant closures for now
and adult entertainment has saved us
once again
we got a quote from cbs 8 judge joel r
wolfiel who previously granted a similar
temporary restraining order for cheetahs
gentlemen club and pacers
showgirls international wrote in his
nine page ruling that the state of
california and san diego county
have not provided evidence tying the
spread of covid 19
or lack of intensive care unit bed
capacity
to live entertainment or businesses with
restaurant service so to be very clear
in essence what this judge is saying and
i like you judge
what he's saying is guys there's no
evidence
that closing strip clubs or restaurants
is causing anyone to have covet and by
the way he's right there is no
evidence of it san diego i want you to
picture san diego people
google san diego google weather in san
diego michael can you google weather in
san diego
michael's from san diego he knows a
little something about san diego how's
the weather in san diego today
i think it's going to be probably pretty
decent okay san diego right now it's 60
degrees it's sunny it's
clear skies and as the day goes on it's
going to get nice and warmer and warmer
and warmer again
this is the reason that people live in
socal
it's going to be a high of 73 just a
perfect
no humidity none of that stuff just
beautiful beach day
as it always is in san diego okay they
always there's a joke about you know the
cushiest job in the world is to be the
weatherman in san diego
basically what this what this judge is
saying
is you guys think you can just close
down businesses
and destroy lives because you have this
sort of amorphous idea
that this virus is spreading in these
places but you have shown no evidence
and me as a judge it's my job to decide
what is and isn't legal that's what the
judiciary does that's what judges do
right let's just do a quick civics thing
guys we have three branches of
government you know what they all do
we've got the executive well we've got
the legislative branch let's do that
first they're the ones that are supposed
to
write the laws so you get a bunch of
congress people and senators they write
laws
then you've got the executive branch you
know what they do they sign those laws
into law and then you know what the
judicial branch does it makes sure
those things are legal and then we've
got a series of checks and balances to
make sure that no branch gets too
powerful now we don't
really operate this way anymore because
we've given a tremendous amount of power
to the executive branch
to do things with executive orders that
by the way both sides
do but what's happening here is actually
the system working here's a guy going
well hey
hang on i'm supposed to be the one to
make sure that these laws are legal that
these
that there's any sort of judicial reason
that these laws can be put into place
but you guys aren't showing me any
evidence that we should just destroy
businesses destroy restaurants destroy
strip clubs which are a very important
form of entertainment and he's going
ahead and saying we're not going to have
that anymore well this guy
in my opinion at this point is a hero we
need
more and more judges to stand up we know
about i did the video a couple days ago
about the sheriff
in uh i believe it's in ventura county
who's saying that we're not going to
enforce these things
none of this diminishes the reality of
covet i know someone that has covered
right now she's a relatively young
person roughly my age and she's been a
little under the weather for the last
couple days
we had to cancel a meeting because she
wasn't feeling great we rescheduled it
for tomorrow she's going to be okay
we know that this is a virus with a 99
recovery rate we've decided to destroy
the world and destroy
everything that was once good because of
it and again
i just don't think this is about covet
anymore i think it's about something
far more nefarious as aoc said i use the
word nefarious all the time i think i
i think i got that to her i think
something else is actually happening
here uh
anyway i'm glad to see that some cities
are fighting back
and and my personal belief is that you
should fight back however you can
in your life for example i got an
illegal haircut in my house today
come and get me eric garcetti you
dirtbag
all right guys uh one more show tomorrow
and then i'm actually not doing any
direct messages for the rest of the year
i'm giving my guys some extended time
uh to enjoy christmas and enjoy the end
of the year i will be
at turning point student action summit
giving us
talk on monday which as i said yesterday
it's my first public gig
since that very gig last year because
these lockdowns destroyed my book tour
and everything else
and i'm hoping to get back out on tour
in 2021 we shall see
if that happens but we will post that
public talk which i can't wait to do
just be great to just be with people
again and then
i'm going to take a little time and just
hit the beach and not be tweeting as
much and i'll do some stuff on
reubenreport.com and maybe i'll do
little little videos that we're going to
put up and then we have some end of year
stuff for you guys
uh if you haven't watched it yet check
out part two of my interview with
abigail
schreier who wrote a really wonderful
book on sort of
the the virus going across the country
right now related to all of these trans
issues and young girls specifically who
are transitioning and mass and why it's
become such a
such a big issue for everybody that's
all for me
so i'll see you guys tomorrow have a
great day everybody and if you're in san
diego
get out to a strip club support your
local strippers
you